in the season 2 finale while at the
house of the undying then he has a
vision of the throne room presumably at
the end of the show broken and covered
in either ash or snow in season 4
episode 2 bran has a similar vision
before I continue let me just say this
while prophecies in Game of Thrones
don't literally come true visions on the
other hand do we know this for a fact as
in the sixth episode of the sixth season
Brenner saved multiple visions of the
past and future events and one of his
visions from the future already came
true in the season 6 finale
Brent's vision of the exploding wildfire
the remaining two visions that are yet
to be seen at the share of a dragon
flying above King's Landing and one in
which brain sees King's Landing in
Minter with an empty throne room that
has its rule enough the question we all
need to ask is was this vision of the
throne room really a vision of a future
event or rather a vision of the past
event as we can see in these visions the
throne room still has a certain point in
star on the window above the iron throne
however ever since Cersei destroyed the
entire faith militant there was no seven
Pony star about the UH throne in case
you have not noticed shortly after the
coronation of Cersei Lannister the Great
Hall changed significantly the
seven-point starts in the windows
replaced with the Lannisters digial with
the lion facing towards the throne as
well as the seven pointed star about the
throne cell being replaced with a sigil
of house lannister showing stars his new
reign SOI brands and then his vision of
the throne room was a vision of a future
when the crown would have to change its
ruler and the ruler would have to bring
the seven points tarts back and place it
onto the windows taking into account
that Neerja an ordinary star influenced
by the faith of the seven possibility of
either of them taking the throne and
redecorating the windows for the army of
the Dead is marching South to kill them
all seems very unlikely to sail East
upon re-watching shown multiple times
and upon reconsidering all those facts
and hence I made a theory that brains
and Dana's vision of the throne room is
not one of the visions of the future
events but rather a vision of the past
event what I'm proposing is that red
keef will not get destroyed by anyone in
present but rather by the Mad King and
brain in the past this would also be the
last big twist showrunners are going to
pull out I'm aware that most of you are
very confused at a moment and are
probably thinking if the red key was
destroying the past then how is there
the red cape in the present but give me
a chance to explain so far we've learned
that brain is able to affect the past
but it's yet to be seen if you can
change it as well in season 6 episode 5
sv l remember brainwashed into a young
willis resulting in brainwashing into
present-day horror as well who
Andrew brands control assisted branimir
in their escape out of the Cape Mira
desperate and scared screams hold the
door still in the regional pest of
Winterfell brand sees young villas
collapse after his mind returns to his
body horror keeps screaming hold the
door repeatedly until it slurs into
horror basically brands possession of
villas in his vision of the past broke
young villas his mind and he hears the
echoes of mere screams which made his
mind simple and only capable repeating a
form of the last words he heard before
his death horror however well this
improved that brain is able to affect
the past it has not proved that brand
can change it which is necessary for a
theory of mind it introduced with
earlier but we'll get there basically
horror was always horror for as long as
brand new him bran may be the reason
that young villas became horror but the
key point is that bran did not actually
change the past
he said the past on course that will
become the present the existing present
time did not change horror did not
become horror just now he's been that
veil along it might have happened
because of bran but it was always done
in this case brain is not changing the
course of history is playing his part in
a predetermined chain of events
everything brand has done in the past
has already been done and we can already
feel the effects of those actions in the
present the question is what other
things has brain affected in the past
did he build a wall for the whispers the
Mad King heard that eventually caused
him to go mad were actually brands
whispers was it brain himself who made
the Mad King mad book readers as well as
show watcher soul I have heard many
tales of the Mad King then his father in
John's grandfather drooler of the Seven
Kingdoms before Robert Baratheon user of
the throne Aerys was known as unstable
and paranoid convinced that those around
him were conspiring
however errors the second was in fact
not always mad while somewhat arrogant
and hot-tempered he was also charming
and ambitious in his earlier age when
his reign started he made the realm
recover from the events at summer hall
from the war every stephen proclaimed
that his goal was to be cool there is
the great orators device however Ariston
started hearing voices that eventually
made him mad and paranoid
we know that Mad King was repeatedly
saying burned a mole in the later stages
of his life
could I behold the door incident to
point out as I already pointed out the
king was not always mad then all of a
sudden one day something happened that
got him obsessed with a particular
phrase that caused him to mentally slip
sounds familiar this is exactly the same
thing that happened with Hodor
what if it will be bran will choke back
in time to warn heir staggering about
the night
king and his army only to realize it's
him and his warning words that actually
made their is mad which result with the
Mad King burning the Starks it's
definitely not out of the realm of
possibility is that the reason why
you're skeptic the phrase burn demo is
because Brent reveled back and tried to
warn him of the approaching White
Walkers there's evidence that brent has
had an even greater impact on the past
bran shares his name with the many
legendary Brandon Starks throughout the
history of his house the most famous of
these is brent builder the architect of
the wall there's a theory claiming all
of the great achievements by these
brands were made possible because the
current brand influenced them through
whispers the major piece of evidence for
this theory comes from George RR
Martin's first book in which it's noted
that brands character old man wood
something speak to brand as if he was
one of his ancestors the passage reads
she had lived so long matter had told me
once that although Brandon Starks had
become one person in her head in the
video about the history of Westeros in
the game terms DVD is there were
glimpses of bran the Builder being
carried on a platform
who else is crippled yeah exactly to
make things more interesting the video
has been narrated by Isaac Hempstead
Wright who plays brain on the show in my
opinion this image of bran the Builder
being carried on the platform was most
certainly a subtle hint that the show
creators had given in the video anyways
what I'm proposing in my theory that I
mentioned the beginning of this video is
that the popular Sam Chino brand not
being able to change the past or present
is not correct in my opinion we will see
a huge twist regarding of how much
influence bran can have over the past
given his tendency to ignore the advice
so visor people and his irresponsible
use of his powers there's a good chance
that we could see bran attempting to
change the past let's take a look on a
scene from season 6 episode 3 as Ned
runs it at the tower to finally in our
brain calls out to him net stops to look
around but he's confused because he
cannot find the source of the voice
before brain can discover what's in the
tower for himself the three-eyed raven
brings both of them out of the past it's
very important to highlight that when
brain questioned whether or not his
father heard him the three-eyed raven
did not deny the possibility of that
being true he heard me maybe
maybe he heard the wind he had me the
past is already written the ink is
dropping in fact he seemed to think that
it could be the case but nevertheless he
born in bran to leave the vision as soon
as possible whereupon he warned bran not
to interfere with the past maybe he knew
that bran had the power to make contact
with other people in this vision and
didn't want bran to accidentally change
the course of history just like on the
show Eddard Stark also seemingly hurt
his future son's voice in the books as
well let's take a look on brains last
chapter in The Dance with Dragons Lord
Eddard Stark set up on a rock beside the
deep black pool in the godswood the pale
roots of the heart tree twisting around
him like in old man's gnarled arms the
great sir dies lay across Lord Eddard
slab and he was cleaning the blade with
an oil cloth Winterfell bran whispered
his father looked up who's there he
asked if naturally did hear his future
son's voice then bran could in fact be
able to change the past which would
automatically change the present - in my
opinion brain has already changed the
past by calling out for his father it
may have not been a significant change
but it could still prove that he is able
to do so let me remind you that Brent
called out to his father in episode 3 of
season six
however season six finale proved that
bran has actually rewritten the past as
we can see that Ned now always hears
brain and turns around so there
certainly is a chance that bran can
actually change the past and in some way
communicate with people from different
time periods and if sure this would be a
major game changer guarding the outcome
of the Great War perhaps the three-eyed
Raven was wrong when he said that the
past is already written
additionally in this scene he seems to
know that brain will huge power and is
in fact able to rewrite history because
the brain could not do it then what
would be the point of him warning bran
or to interfere with the past but my
theory brain will do exactly what the
three-eyed raven warned him not to do
and it will result with the Mad King
burning down the whole Capitol as I
already said this would explain the
seven-pointed star being above the Iron
Throne even though there isn't one ever
since search to destroy the high Sparrow
in the faith militant Brennan then his
vision of what we assume is a vision of
a future event would turn out to be one
of the visions of the past events if the
story of mine comes show even though
most of the current characters would
still be around it would certainly
change the course of history and present
for example brands to be born Ned and
Catelyn as the Mad King already killed
Ned's brother devil supposed to Mary
Kathleen before he burned down the
Capitol however some of the main
characters like for an example
Jamie would be burned alive along with
the Mad King as he wasn't read keep as
well and this will result with some main
characters that are dead to be alive in
the present one of those would be Ned
Stark since with Jamie being dead King
Joffrey would not exist in a rewritten
history and that star could not be
beheaded for false reason anyways this
theory of mine could be a product of my
were thinking and Brandon Dana's vision
of the throne room might actually be a
vision of the future event as the seven
pointed star above the Iron Throne could
be nothing more than a continue in the
mistake